good day I'm Edmund Robinson and welcome
to my talk on sunny day flooding looking
at the effects of tidal changes on
coastal areas of the USA
oh good morning and welcome to this talk
on sunny day flooding my name is Edmund
Robinson I'm an actual analyst for
reinsurance and this is a a topic that
relates to both the insurance and and
reinsurance industry and also the
finance industry as well what I normally
do with these talks are just given
initial a bit of initial information of
what sort of domains and what sort of
infamy what parts of the system going to
be touching in the talk and that's one
of the things I like about the Wolfram
language is that there are many
different knowledge domains that you can
touch and you really don't have to go
out a lot to look for many different
sort of packages or or libraries or
anything like that and one of the great
things about that as well is that it all
just sort of works so today some of the
things you'll see is a data import of
navigation some package development some
geographic visualization and modeling
some knowledge base stuff statistics I
was gonna put in a bit of a
machine-learning but it didn't didn't
make it it didn't make the cut some data
about validation and visualization and
some user interface construction as well
so let's just start off and talk about
what exactly is sunny day flooding and
this is flooding sometimes it's also
called nuisance flooding and this is
flooding that occurs without a weather
event so it's just strictly from tidal
changes where either there's been some
subsistence in in the landmass or that
there's the tides are just are
increasing in height over time so where
before it would only come up to the
middle of the beach now it's coming up
to the beach and into the sort of like
the little grass park behind it there
are increasing in currencies of this you
can find many articles online that
discuss it and and it's and it's
increase in the impacts that it's having
one of the critical areas are some
economical and social impacts one top
story that we can refer to is a very
small community in the US where it costs
over
forty-eight million dollars to relocate
this small community and this is a
community of less than fifty households
and so you just can imagine if this
starts happening and it's not not a very
complex community either in terms of
infrastructure so if this continues to
happen in and if this is a trend where
more and more towns or cities and major
cities start to experience nuisance and
coastal flooding it's going to be a very
expensive proposition indeed and they're
also industry and governmental impacts
if you can imagine that municipalities
that border of coastal municipalities a
lot of their revenue comes from land tax
and so once the mirror is evidence that
buyers are getting hip to this issue of
sunny day or nuisance flooding and so
they're buying further inland and not so
much buying on on the coast
that means property values go down as
property values go down property taxes
go down and this creates an issue for
revenue for capital projects creates an
engine for solvency of these
municipalities bonds that they issue to
fund some of their capital projects and
one of the interesting things that's
come out of this is that a bit of
research by the Guardian uncovered a set
of documents from the 1980s that sort of
prove or directly speak to the fact that
the oil industry knew back in the 1980s
that burning fossil fuels was not ideal
for the climate but they ended up sort
of squashing that research from their
own scientist and when this was found
out now what we're seeing is more well
cities now are deciding to say well you
know what you knew about this
you knew about this problem you squash
the research you know what I've got to
build dams I've got to install pumps
I've got to set up new levees I don't
have the money for this who's gonna pay
for it hmm oil industry let's charge
them for it so you're having these large
suits New York recently joined in
I think Massachusetts is another one
that's in so there's a lot of
while increasingly more cities that are
saying the oil industry has to pay
similar to what's happened in the
tobacco industry where they had research
that sort of proved the harmfulness of
tobacco and nicotine and they sort of
marketed it marketed it away so lots of
issues surrounding beyond just you know
getting your feet your feet wet as you
walk down a sidewalk so this exercise
that I did I was curious about this to
figure out you know K well how much is
this is hype how much of this is real
like is there really a problem here or
is it just that we have better reporting
you know because as technology and and
people move into more areas more things
get reported more quickly and easily so
I took it about myself to start to look
at this and these are the steps that I
went through first locating some of the
what data I needed finding out how to
access that data because sometimes you
know stuffs there but there's a problem
and getting it the biggest part of any
sort of data project is wrangling at
getting in into a form that you can work
with it finally doing some analysis of
those results and then we'll look at
some observations and further analysis
from there so locating the data I've
discovered there's two main sources that
we can get information from one is known
as tides and currents and the other is
the National Weather Service National
Weather Service so it's kind of an
interesting relationship because NOAA
tides and currents they actually are
responsible for the tidal stations that
do all the recording of all these of all
these metrics like temperature and
salinity and the wave height and all
this all this sort of business but it's
actually the National Weather Service
that sets the thresholds for what is a
flood and what isn't a flood and there
were some issues lining up the data
because of that difference but we
managed to overcome it so when I say
tidal stage acts stages what am I
talking about for this is only gonna be
three stages that we're interested in
well that I was interested in one is the
actions stage and that's the height of
the water where municipalities and they
start to say you know what we might have
to do something here that
what is getting kind of high the next
stage is the flood stage now this would
be when you're sort of you know might
just be around your ankles or just on
your feet and then it's the moderate
stage where you're sort of starting to
get some material property damage and
things like that so these are actually
these stages of course geared more
towards weather events select flooding
from rainfall where you know things are
steadily going up and up and up and not
so much geared for tidal changes but the
heights
especially the flood stage is when you
would have salt water ingress on
sidewalks and things like that from from
king tides and the like so luckily for
me the NOAA has a really well defined
API that allows you to access that data
they have lots of different options so
what I did there is I put together a
small package that that goes through and
and takes care of speaking to speaking
to NOAA's API has some error checking
and some other things in there and
eventually this will probably find its
way to the function repository and that
just made it easy for me to to
institutionalize that and I just have to
repeat that code everywhere I could just
call by my tides and currents function
and get the information out that I that
I needed so you're just some pieces and
this is just an example of how you call
it so you need to have the station ID
which it expects to be a string some
begin and end dates and then some of
their API keys to to tell it what to do
and you get out of that with with this
other function a helper function so this
is just pulling all of the records for
all of the observations for two days and
you get from that your data set where
you've got a couple of different things
here you got low you've got high you've
got lower low so Louis age high so low
is L high is age lower lower lower low
is LL and
hi is HH and we're really going to be
focusing on the higher high so there's
like high tides a far above us you know
a certain percentile of what they
normally would be the National Weather
Service data was a little more difficult
to get at each station has a hydrograph
page as you can see here but one of the
problems is there isn't a data API
available so the options were either do
some web scraping you know you can do
that with web execute and things like
that but I actually took the old
fashioned route and made some phone
calls and actually talked to people
shock horror and and I was able to get
someone at the National Weather Service
to send me a dataset that had their IDs
for the stations and also NOAA's IDs for
the stations and the flood threshold
information that I need it so when all
else fails actually talk to people and
this is actually interesting one because
you actually see here for this station
this yellow area here is the action
stage and this minor area here is
actually the flood stage and so you can
see over the past couple of days they
have been in minor flooding and this is
a a tidal station as you can see by the
the the change in heights
okay so let's start some data wrangling
the the station data for NOAA and their
sensors is a big XML listing that you
can grab it from so it was able to
import that and with a bit of massaging
of XML elements in Wolfram come up with
a data set that has the name the ID the
location and the list of sensors that
are available at that particular station
did a quick filter down just to select
the stations that only had that only had
a water level sensor so not all of them
have a water level sensor and so what we
want to do we don't need those other
ones so we just dropped those ones off
so we went from 371 down to 300 so we
lost 71 and we can plot that quite
easily with dynamic geographic where we
can go in and zoom into to any
particular station that we we want to
have a look at sort of just like see
where it is and if it's near you know a
populated area or things like that as I
mentioned for for the flood state
information I got a download and then
from there I just massaged it a bit and
and threw it in a data set here I don't
have all that code here but I just see
relized it and we just deserialize it
here and you can see the information
that I want got out of that so this is
the NOAA ID the information they didn't
have levels for all locations and this
considerably less here it's only 145 we
had 300 in the other set but and I also
have links to the hydrograph pages so
this data isn't it exists but it's sort
of incomplete but it's the best that we
can do at this at the moment and then
just joining the two together so these
purple ones are the ones that have that
are in both datasets and have a water
level sensor and the other ones are in
both datasets so both datasets have a
water level sensor and have a non zero
flood stage threshold and the the red
ones are the ones that do not meet those
qualifications
so we can do a quick little interface
with dynamic Geographics again where you
can zoom in on a particular area and you
click there and you can see down here
that our station ID changes as we go
through so we can use this to pick which
station you want to work on and then and
then flow through from there so there's
this concept of well.there of stationed
atoms because every every epoch or so
which is I think it's like 30 years or
20 years they go through and they sort
of reset their level and some of the
stations may be on the new data and some
of the stations maybe the old datum so
you sort of know need to know which to
Adam you're on so you can make
adjustments so that you get the correct
water level and I did not include those
calculations here but just showing you
that you know that stuff is there and
then you can start picking out
historical data sets there are some
limitations on the NOAA API where you
cannot just go and say give me the last
50 years worth of data they limit how
much you can pull at a time so using the
the API function and using a bit of
storing data back down with wdx files
and sort of you know making date ranges
that are over here I was able to just
sort of recreate and keeping in keeping
you below their threshold of returning
me an error saying okay you've taken too
much data so we get that and we can for
so now we're dealing with the wilmington
station of course cuz that's what we
selected and just looking at the highest
the highest 20 tides measured and you
can already see here that we're sort of
like in 2 and above and if we go back up
to the the the station data here sorry
going down you can see that the flood
stage starts at 1 point 6 so it starts
at 1 point 6 and we already see you have
a lot of information here that sort of
says okay that's been happening again
there's some further adjustments you can
make
by sort of taking out the data whenever
there was a tropical storm or something
like that in the area unfortunately NOAA
does not have an API that allows you to
download all those shape files but it
would be if you could get that
information then it's just a matter of
you know getting the shapefile for the
cone expanding it a bit saying okay
doing a bit of geodetic computation to
find out which stations lying in that
area use the dates wipe those those
values out so you wouldn't have that in
there so just keep in mind that going
forward storm surge from tropical events
are included in this but I don't think
that it makes that much of a difference
and you'll see why so action days again
those are the days where you may have to
do something mint valleys may have to do
something there are quite a few in here
but we are looking we have pulled from
1982 to 2019 so there's quite a lot of
days if we look at how many action days
there are per year you can see okay
there is some cyclicality here but there
also is a an increasing trend just by I
to say okay action days have been going
up at this particular station over the
last 20 years
sorry 40 years because we're starting
from 1980 going forward
same thing for if we look at flood days
we can see oh man this looks pretty bad
can this actually be real that there's
been a year where they've been over 100
flood days for this particular station
location so I said okay well how many
how many what's like the largest amount
of flood days in a particular months
it's 25 so hey well maybe I'm doing the
data calculation wrong there must be on
my side
so actually called back to to my contact
at NOAA and they were like no no that's
correct that that particular station has
been having has been undone date you
know it's been consistently experiencing
flood levels and it's just like the
other station that we looked hydrograph
which is a different station where you
sort us in this past week has been two
days where they've been at flood stage
above flood stage so we can look at that
per year which is what this plot does
and just does per month and just as we
scroll through we can just see okay
there's been more and more and more and
there's not really a particular
month or it's not a particular season
it's they're just sort of spread around
as you go along and I think when we get
to 2018 you can see that that's not the
right one somewhere in here there we go
in 2016 you can see that that month
really in October where there was just
like just about every single day there
was an issue with wading in the water
all right so let's try to look at this
over time and just see what's going on
so the first thing when you look back to
see okay what has happened and there's a
very useful function by Anton that does
a bit of quantile regression I find this
is quite useful if you just want to see
how things are behaving so a bit of
dynamic module manipulate you can set up
the quantile regression to look at this
so you got the number of curves above
and below the median how many knots you
want to fit at and what interpolation
order you want to look at so you can do
it linear piecewise quadratic cubic and
then you can either make it sort of more
or less knots and add in more or less
curves so really all you probably need
to do is two curves three knots and a
quadratic interpolation and you you get
a oops
you get an idea of what's going on so
this is the 95th percentile the 5th
percentile and the median so there's a
couple of ways we can look forward to
see what's going to happen we can use
time series analysis and forecasting and
again I've removed the uncertainty from
these plots just to making a little
simple for please presentation so you
can see the actual series that has
happened and then we can see where this
ARMA model
there's no seasonality sitting use of
Sarma just an armor to what it's saying
so 2019 is not included because it only
goes up to September but you can see
that this arma models particularly
there's some more some more flood days
to come and it was pretty much gonna be
a somewhat linear trend going up
you can also use generalized linear
methods with GLM so the best option for
these are Prasanna and gaussian since
we're dealing with counsel they'll be 0
and above so if we do that we can get
some again some interesting plots that
show where they are where they are
predicting they go and is use the AIC to
compare the models and select which one
it has the projected least loss of
information surprisingly it picks this
this metric picks the Gaussian the
linear one so that's that's interesting
and then so also if you have your own
models either from third-party vendors
or from with your internal research or
whatever you can just use long linear
model fit I've set up another data set
here you just map through that with his
properties and then you get you know for
your quadratic or cubic and your your
exponential piece that you want and you
can again use a AIC to select which one
you want and go through and you can sort
of wrap all this up in a little - so
you've got your your your time series
your GLM your your your known models and
which one was picked you can see how
that's sort of developing per month over
time you can also look at how those
action days are behaving this is your
actual flood based each your action days
and your location of your of your of the
station and then some experimental stuff
you can also do is you can sort of look
at how that looks like when you apply
the the topology to the area so here we
can see how the area around the station
is formed and and then we can actually
adjust the sea level and meters here to
see what happens as the sea level rises
and rises now this isn't 100% accurate
because we're not taking into account
gravitational effects water does not lie
level because of the effect of the moon
it's always going to be on an angle
slightly tilted so that's not in here
and also the not certain how good the
resolution of the Geo data is
in here but it's it's all it's all there
for Lao as a starting point so what's to
take away from these I've actually done
this for quite a few of these stations
and there is and it's not the same
everywhere some have a very very strong
signal that there is an increase some of
quite flat and some have have a very
very slight decrease in in trend there
and from that there is no dominant sort
of model across different stations to
say that all stations aren't showing a
linear model or an exponential model or
every station that has an increase they
sort of know one model that says ok this
is the way it's flowing some further
things would be interesting to do
increase the station coverage to go back
out to to the organisations and say you
know has there been any updates and the
datasets that you sent me that we're
sort of like incomplete do you extending
the data back further from 1980 I just
picked that because it's it's it's
really quick to grab that and analyze
the change in higher high tides as well
not just the ones that manage to break
the the the flood stage fish hold
comparing like sort of like the rate of
change across them all and also not on
here but overlaying any information on
subsistence which would be interesting
because some of this could be that you
know maybe the land is dropped by you
know a few centimetres or something and
that's just enough for it for it to make
it over the sand banks or something and
come in so that is that is all I have
for that any any questions